Wow, this is the best day of my life.
Let's go to the lab. But first, here's
what you need to know [music] about the
new Veo 3.1. It now supports highquality
video with [music] audio and flow, which
means you can create long AI videos.
This is the right time to explore your
creativity or create something far more
powerful. [laughter]
Yes, it is now possible to create long
videos using Google Flow. You can
literally build [music] out complete
video sequences, keep the same
characters,
and maintain smooth transitions all the
way through. This is a huge step forward
for creators like us, filmmakers,
storytellers, [music]
and anyone who wants to bring their full
story ideas to life or produce cinematic
AI content [music] that feels real and
flows naturally. I'm going to let the
real me take over this video. Over to
you, bro.
This is beautiful. [laughter]
This is truly beautiful. You can create
better videos than what you've watched.
In fact, after this video, you'll be
able to create something better than
what I've shown you. Because in this
video, I'm going to show you how to
create long videos with consistent
characters using Google's new V3.1 and
Google Flow. My name is Charles. Let's
dive in.
Now, to get started, we're going to go
to deepmind.google/mod/view
and then click try and flow. Here we'll
be able to access Google Flow which is
what we'll be using to create this long
video. So we'll click create with flow
and then we start a new project. Now to
use Google flow you can just click on
scene builder and start creating from
here or you could just go back you know
to the normal V3 interface right here
and start creating. So when you generate
a video here you can just add it to the
scene builder which is Google flow. So
we paste our prompt here and then we
ensure that this is in text to video
because we want to use text to video to
create the first video and then from
that first video we'll build the rest of
the videos from there on. Now we ensure
that in text to video but for this you
can also use frames to video but for the
sake of this tutorial I want to generate
everything here in V3. So now we've
selected text to video and then we click
settings here and we ensure that it's in
the right aspect ratio which is 16:9 and
the number of outputs for me is two and
right here the model I'm using is V 3.1
quality. If you notice V3 is no longer
available here unless you're using an
API. So V3 is no longer available on the
platform. It's just 3.1 and V2. So leave
it on quality. But if you want to save
credits, use V3.1 fast. Now, once we
have all this set, the next thing I'm
going to do is to, you know, use our
prompt and send it. Now, before we send
this prompt, let's look at what I want
to generate. I'm trying to generate a
video, which is a young boy in a lab
wearing um blue coat and all that, lab
coat and all that. And you can see
[snorts] here I described the aesthetic
style in the prompt, the lighting and
the visual look, the color palette, the
camera direction and then what should
happen from 0 to 2 seconds, 3 [snorts]
seconds to 4 seconds, 5 to 8. But
generally
I know V3 is not going to stick with
this, right? V 3.1 will not stick with
this. But I just added it here and here.
This is what the boy is going to say. So
here this is the aesthetic style pixel
style 3D animation the visual look
golden hour sunlight that's kind of
lighting I want you know daylight and
then the color palette which is bright
blue coat orange sunlight metallic
silver gadget and then the camera
direction. From the camera direction I
also detailed what I want the boy to say
for that particular um time or that
shot. Right. So here I said, "Wow, this
is the best day of my life." And then 3
to 4 seconds, let's go to the lab. And
then 5 to 8 seconds. But first, check
out my new podcast studio and all that.
So the next thing is to generate. So we
click here to generate. And boom, we
have our first video right here. So
let's play it.
>> Wow, this is the best day of my life.
Let's go to the lab. But first,
>> if you've not subscribed to this
channel, subscribe. There a lot of
helpful videos here. So like, comment,
and share this video. For the next step,
I'm going to show you a feature that you
can use in V3.1.
V 3.1 has given you the option to edit
your video. So I'm going to edit this
video and add a Chihuahua dog in the
video. So what I'm going to do is to
click on this edit button right here,
and it's going to bring up a new panel.
So I'm going to draw this box here where
I want to insert the object and then
enter this prompt. I'm going to say a
small Chihuahua dog walking and then
send it. And boom, V3.1 has added a
small Chihuahua dog just where I wanted.
Let's play the video.
>> Wow, this is the best day of my life.
Let's go to the lab. But first,
>> you can see here that V3.1 added this
small Chihuahua just where I wanted.
Now, this insert feature is very useful.
Let's say you generate a video and you
want to add a specific thing in that
video. You can just use this feature to
add whatever you want to add to the
video. It could be another character. It
could be something else an object.
Right? So this feature is very useful.
And now yes, we have this video. The
next thing we are going to do is
[snorts] to click on add to scene. So
we're going to click add to scene and
add our first video to scene. It's going
to add it to Google flow which is the
scene builder. So once you've added the
first video to the scene builder which
is Google flow you start extending it
and making that video long. So your
first video is the basic the first one
and then from that video you keep
building it and making it long. So to
access the scene builder click here you
say scene builder and then it will take
you to Google flow. So you can see here
in Google flow I already created you
know this long video and you can see the
different clips in the long video. So,
how did I get these other clips that
matched with the first one? Right. How
did I get these clips? So, once you have
your first video in, what you're going
to do is to click this plus sign here.
You're going to see a plus sign. If you
click that plus sign, you're going to
see extend or jump to. So, what does
jump to do? If I click jump to,
I can just generate a separate clip,
right? I can just enter the text prompt
and generate right here using jump. And
it's going to take that frame, right?
It's going to take the frame from where
you selected and then create another
video, jump to that video, right?
Instead of extending the the clip you
selected. So, it's going to jump to the
end here to create that video with this
frame. Okay. Now, the second one is
extend. What does extend do? So if I
click this plus sign and then click
extend, I'll be able to extend this
particular clip here, right? [snorts]
What should happen next? I'll just enter
my prompt and say oh this this this and
it will generate the video. So for this
particular video here, what I did was to
click here and then click on extend
and then enter the prompt to generate
this particular video. So I enter this
prompt here that says voice. The boy
says it now supports high quality video
with audio in flow. He gestures to the
holographic screen behind him showing
waveforms and clips playing together
seamlessly.
And I send this prompt and boom, he
created this next clip here which is
what is showing here. Let me play it.
>> Here's what you need to know about the
new Veo 3.1. It now supports high
quality video with audio and flow which
means
>> so [snorts] that was the video I
generated. So from here after getting
this video what I did was to click on it
and then click on plus and click extend
and then enter the prompt for the next
video and generated it. I got this video
right here. Let's play it.
>> You can create long AI videos. This is
the right time to explore your
creativity or create.
>> In my school community, I go deep into
showing you step by step how to create
cinematic videos, animated videos, AI
ads and creatives and niche based videos
using different AI tools, not just
Google View 3.1 and Flow. Inside this
community, I'll guide you through
hands-on project to help you build the
skills that can place you in the top 1%
of creative professionals. So, if you're
looking to start a creative agency, you
also learn how to get started and how to
find clients. In fact, in this
community, if there's something around
the AI space that you want to learn and
I haven't covered that topic, you can
make a request for it and I'll go deep
in teaching on that topic. I'll leave
the link to Bran's AI creative network
in the description of this video. I'll
see you inside. So, there's something
else you can do. Let's say you want to
generate another video with a particular
frame in this video. What you can do is
to click on this plus sign and save
frame as asset. So you can see it
automatically saved the frame. So I can
generate a video in flow or inside your
3.1 itself with this particular frame
that I've saved. Right? You can see the
frame here. So I can use this frame as
first frame and generate a different
video. So once you've generated the
third video, you can extend it again
further to the fourth video, the fifth
video. And this is the next video I
generated here. I clicked on this,
clicked here, and then click extend and
enter the prompt that I want to use. And
boom, it gave me this video right here.
So for this particular video, let's play
it
>> or powerful. [laughter]
So now I'm going to extend this last
video further. Right, I'm going to click
on this plus here and click extend and
then paste the prompt that I want to
see. If you're wondering how did I get
this prompt, I got it from Charypity. I
just gave Chajity my idea and then
Charypity helped me come up with the
prompt. So we post our prompt here. And
in Google Flow, remember before you
couldn't use 3.1 in Google Flow, but now
you can use 3.1 quality or fast. I'm
still using the quality version. Okay.
So, I've noticed that quality gives
better um better videos, right?
Especially when you're using frames to
video. So, once we paste our prompt, we
just generate. So, let's work on this
prompt. And then we enter this prompt
here where it says I'm more powerful,
more creative than ever. I'll create
something that will shake the world and
all that. So, we enter this prompt to
extend the video further. Once we have
this, we just click generate. And you
can see here that it is extending this
video. So from here the video is just
going to flow and blend into the next
video that it's creating. Now let's say
you have generated clips and probably
you want to delete a few from the videos
that you have generated here in flow.
What you're going to do is click this
icon here and then click on anyone to
remove the video. So it allow you delete
any video from this flow right here. And
if you're done, you want to download it,
you just click on this download button
here. So using flow is quite easy. It
helps, you know, it helps your work.
Let's say you're trying to create um a
long video, more like a faceless channel
type of video where someone is speaking.
This is the best way to use it, right?
You generate the first part and then you
continue, you generate the next. What
you just have to change would probably
be the speech, right? That will be the
only thing to change. Now, if you notice
in these four videos, the characters are
the same. It did not change. And the
next one is still going to be the same.
So, let's play it so you'll see the
flow. The next one has been generated.
I've extended it.
>> I'm more powerful, more creative than
ever. I will create something that will
shake the world.
>> Wow.
>> So, you can see I've added to this part.
So here what I can do is to trim it,
right? I can reduce it from here and
then reduce this part of the video. Trim
it back a bit so that it will just blend
in. So let me play it from here.
[laughter]
>> I'm more powerful, more creative than
ever. I will create something that will
shake the world.
So, if you notice, it cut the speech
actually because um the speech was
actually too long. I had the feeling
that it's going to cut it. So, if you're
trying to generate a video in your tree,
just ensure that your speech is not too
long or else it's going to cut it down.
You just have 8 seconds to, you know, to
use, right? So, let's play the video
again. This time, let's play it from the
beginning.
Let's see how it flows.
>> Wow, this is the best day of my life.
Let's go to the lab. But first, here's
what you need to know about the new Veo
3.1. It now supports highquality video
with audio and flow, which means you can
create long AI videos. This is the right
time to explore your creativity or
create something far more powerful.
[laughter]
I'm more powerful, more creative than
ever. I will create something that will
shake the world.
>> Now, this is beautiful. Once you're done
with creating your full video, you
download. Like I said, you can as well
make it even longer. Add more clips.
Click here, extend it further, give it
more ideas. Now, let's say you don't
want to use this scene and you want to
change the whole scene, right? And you
don't want it to blend. You just want a
totally different scene with another
character. What you can do is to come
here and ensure that it's in frames to
video. And then you upload the image,
right? And use it to create that next
scene or just use text to video. And
once you create it, it's going to add it
in flow. And then after creating that
video, you just extend extend extend
until that scene is done. And then if
you want another scene, you use frames
to video, generate a video, and then
extend that, extend that until you get
to what you want. So once you're done
with all this, what you can do is to
download it. So you click on download to
download and it's going to download this
videos right here and you can take it to
capcot or any video editing tool to edit
further right it's not going to perfect
here in flow you still need to take it
to like any editing tool like cap cut or
premier pro to ensure that they are
properly trimmed and you know they flow
seamlessly and in the editing tool you
can also add like sound effects
background music and all that to just um
improve the vibe of the video. So, I
downloaded this video and then edited it
further in Capcot, which is pretty
basic, and got this video here.
>> Wow, this is the best day of my life.
Let's go to the lab. But first, here's
what you need to know about the new Veo
3.1. It now supports highquality video
with audio and flow, which means you can
create long AI [music] videos. This is
the right time to explore your
creativity or create something far more
powerful. [laughter]
And then for the second intro video that
I showed you, I used first frame and
last frame. However, I did not use
Google flow. I used the normal view 3.1
here. I use this normal interface. I
generated it using first frame and last
frame. And it's just like pretty basic,
right? So this is the first frame and
last frame. I generated the first uh
part of the video. And then for this
part where he was standing and talking,
I just used the first frame of, you
know, the video to get this part. And
then for this part where it's more like
a close shot, I used the frame of a
close shot in a close shot of him or me.
And then uh yeah, so basically I used
like first frame, last frame to achieve
this result. And then
I got this
>> [music]
>> Yes, it is now possible to create long
videos using Google Flow. You can
literally build out complete video
sequences, keep the same characters
and maintain smooth transitions all the
way through. This is a huge step forward
for creators like us, filmmakers,
storytellers, [music]
and anyone who wants to bring their full
story ideas to life or produce cinematic
AI content that feels real and flows
naturally. I'm going to let the real me
take over this video. Over to you, bro.
This is beautiful.
So, it's that easy to create long videos
or consistent characters. But if you're
having issues, you're trying, you're not
getting the result, what I'll suggest
you do is to use the link in the
description to join my private community
where I can, you know, jump on a call
with you. You ask me the question in the
call and I'll help you um resolve your
issues. It's better way to connect with
you. So I can't do that here on YouTube.
So my private community, I go live, I
take questions, you know, we discuss,
get your issues and all that. So um if
you have not joined Brian's AI creative
network, you can join it. That way I'll
be able to help you. If you're not
subscribed to this channel, subscribe
because there are lot of helpful videos
here. In fact, if you're not part of
this channel, you're missing out. So,
subscribe, like, and leave a comment.
I've created this video because I know
it's going to help you. So, watch this
video next. I'll see you there.